this is a pepper panic saga level 89
walkthrough video we're going to
complete the level and we're going to
explain our decisions as we go i made
this video yesterday afternoon and as
for a request that i had in our group
pepper panic add me and level tips group
and I kind of played fast and I think I
missed some point so I'm going to go
ahead and record a new track over top
and I'm just going to pause the video
here and there so that I can explain why
I did what I did if you played this
level before you know it's difficult and
it's difficult for a few different
reasons the statues are hard to get to
you got mr. Claus up there he's out to
steal the peppers and get rid of your
progress and what you need to do is you
need to grow yellow and red peppers that
are caged below to explode them while
they're sitting right next to the
statues and you have to avoid mr. Claus
I should go so in the beginning with him
starting at the top we want to UM we
still want to grow our red and our
yellows but we're looking for other
matches that will bring more of those
onto the board while he's up there so
that we won't really lose any red and
yellows as he moves his way down so the
first couple matches we make are going
to just be to drop new peppers onto the
board and then we get this one here
that's a vertical shockwave is going to
hit a statue so we want to make that all
the time
and we just want to keep continuing the
clear out space and set up more red
yellow matches and even when you see in
LA so even when ever you know whenever
you don't make them how you make a match
that's not important towards growing
these peppers when they drop you can get
good matches now on this next one we can
match the red pepper on the left with
the one grown pepper that we have and
then that's going to cause the two above
it to drop and make another match right
away so we'll make that match
alright then we'll just look over the
board and see mr. Claus is down towards
the bottom now so now we want to just
grow them as fast as we can at the top
on this one we don't really have like a
great match we don't really want to move
the red one off to the side by itself so
we won't match that will just match make
a match in the middle and that'll bring
more peppers in this is a good one we
pause that for a minute that was a good
match because it set up the five pepper
match and that'll knock him out for one
move and grow the yellows really quickly
slow the bread because the cages will
hold those will split another red here
because whenever whenever the board
clears out whichever however much growth
we have it will add to that by the cage
is protecting those when he goes by
now when you're making your decisions up
here I mean you do want to it it's ideal
to focus on one color but what I said
about the cages means that growing
either one is going to be okay and like
I say on the guide which if you haven't
read our full pepper panic saga level 89
guided pepper panic tips I suggest you
do that first because you'll understand
a little bit more about why we're doing
what we're doing but you definitely need
to make matches that will bring lots of
these colors red and yellow peppers onto
the board so that you can you know
continue to explode them now we'll start
a chain reaction with the red and that
will give us a lot of damage to the
statues and get us started out
alright so sometimes when you're doing
that yellow ones fall in place and they
kind of remove that some of those
statues it's not ideal but it's fine and
we still want to grow the yellow because
there's enough of them that are they're
going to do damage to the statues so
we'll continue trying to grow our yellow
and you see you want to keep making
matches that are going to line things up
and you get an L match like that one
you're definitely gonna want to make it
because it's going to grow yellow this
one is a little less than ideal because
it's going to free this one from the
cage but there's no other good matches
if you look around the board to make so
this is going to be the best match
and you see the red aren't really
important at all anymore you just match
those whenever they're going to set up a
match where you can explore the yellow
okay so when you get to this point you
don't really have a lot of good yellow
matches up top and this is this will
make a stage five but it won't start an
explosion so you're going to want to
make this match more for the fact that
it will bring some more peppers down
here because you can't really protect
the ones that you have up top and you
can't match them so
now the screen mats will clear a row and
hopefully to drop a yellow onto the
board so that we can explode something
over here
now you don't really want to move that
one away from the statues but you have
to get a chain reaction because we only
have four four matches left our four
moves left I should say and we got a
little a little bit lucky with the drop
there where we got a shock wave going
cross ways but we made the best moves as
we went and that's all you can really do
you can't plan on the lock but it
happens and you know making the right
decision makes it more likely that it's
going to happen so I hope that this was
helpful and you'll be able to complete
the level after watching it as mentioned
this was a this was for a request in our
group you're welcome to join the the
address is in the description of this
video we have a lot of players there who
are helpful and like the you know talk
about the different levels and how they
got through them make sure you take a
second to like this video if you found
it helpful and subscribe to our channel
those things really help us out as far
as showing up in the search for YouTube
and we appreciate it when you do that if
you got any questions leave a comment
below and hopefully you'll finish the
level right now thanks